الكاتب المصري عبد الرحيم كمال تحدث عبر
حسابه حول الاهانه التي يتعرض لها
الفنانون حاليا القى اللوم على الانترنت
الذي كسر الحاجز بين الفنان والجمهور وجعل
الاساءه امرا طبيعيا في حين ان الفنان لا
يملكوا ميزه النجديه في الرد كان ذلك في
يناير الماضي بعد صدور فيلم اصحاب ولا اعز
عندما كانت الفنانه منى زكي هدفا مصباحا
امام الجمهور بسبب مشهدا صن فعل انه يخالف
المعايير المجتمعيه عبر انستغرام نشرت
الفنانه لقاء الخميس في مقاطع تناشد فيها
متابعيها باحترام الاختلاف والخلفيه التي
جاء منها الناس دون اهانه او تقليل وقالت
ان الفنان مجرد انسان يسعد ويتاثر بالظروف
من الممكن ان يمر بها ازماته اسريه
الفنانه بشرى دعمت لقاء عبر حسابها وقالت
ان الفنانين نبض المجتمع مش الحيطه
المايله بتاعت المجتمع لقاء هاجمت ايضا
الصحافه المجتزا التي تقطع الكلام بحثا عن
تراند على حده وصف فيها في كل مكان يعاني
كثير من الشخصيات العامه من اساءات
اللفظيه عنيفه من متابعهم لاي سبب كان
بعضهم يقرر الاختفاء تماما من ان على
منصات حمايه لصحته العقليه والكثير من
فنانين مصري يتحدثون عن هذه الظاهره
الفنانه نيللي كريم عبرت في تصريحات
تلفزيونيه خلال العام الماضي عن اسياها من
النقد الهدا من الفنانين والحديث عن
ازماتهم باستمرار واتهمت مواقع التواصل
بتضخيم المشكله الفنانه يسرا انتقدت مواقع
التواصل الى احد اللقاءات موضحه ان
السوشيال ميديا تظهر الفنان طوال الوقت
وكانه شياطين كما انها قيدت حريات
الفنانين اكثر من اي وقت نضع
الفنانه الشابه ميان السيد عبرت عن
مدديقها واسياها من جرعات الاهانه والتنمر
التي طلتها اثناء تواجدها في مهرجان
الجونه في عام 2021 وذلك عبر ستورز نشرتها
عبر حسابها على انستغرام اما الفنان خالد
الصاوي كان له راي مختلف حيث رفض فكره
الهجوم على مواقع التواصل رغم الحده
والعنف واقر بصعوبه سيطره على ما يصدر عن
الناس على منصات المختلفه
[موسيقى]
من القاهره عبر الهاتف الفنانه لقاء
الخميسي لقائي يسعد صباحك شكرا على تواجدك
معنا صباح العربيه اهلا بك صباح الخير
اهلا بك حبيبتي اهلا بك
تعتقدين ان الفنان بات هدفا مستباح
للجمهور الانتقادته
الاول
ودائما بخير وسعاده
صعب قوي لانه الواضح ان هو دخل في ماده
بعيد وماذا قوي احنا بقى لنا سنين بالوضع
ده يعني انا بس عايزه اقول الاول
من دول مختلفه للتبادل الثقافات اللي حريه
الراي واحترام الاخر الواضح انها قلبت
بشكل مؤذي جدا لناس كثير قوي لدرجه انه في
ناس بتنتحر وفي ناس بتكتئب وفي ناس
بتتعالج بسبب التنمر اللي على السوشيال
ميديا همم اللي هو اصلا شيء مش لطيف
تفضلي في ناس بتقول انه انتم قررتوا
تكونوا تحت الاضواء بالتالي يجب عليكم انه
تتهبلوا النقد وان كان جارح فهناك رؤساء
دول تتعرض للنقت من قبل البعض
سواء على السوشيال ميديا او عبر وسائل
الاعلام
تمام لا هو انا ممكن عن طاقه حضرتك او
حضرتك تنقليني ولكن كل الحريه لكن في حدود
الانتقاد في حدود للحوار في حدود لان انت
ما تدخليش فعلتي ما تدخليش في عرضي وما
تشتمينيش وما تقرريش حاجات انت ما
تعرفيهاش احنا دلوقتي بنحاكم الرؤساء على
حسب النتائج اللي النتائج اللي بيقدموها
تمام واورائهم كلها مفتوحه لكن انت تعرف
عندي ايه في بيتي انت تعرف علاقتي بقى عن
عامله ازاي مع اهلي بتعرف تفاصيل حياتي
انا بامر بايه فكره ان انت تقول الوقت
شايف الممثل او الفنان او المطرب انه بي-
بي- بيرمي فلوس على الارض لانه مش حاسس
بحاجه انه ما عندوش مشاكل الكلام ده مش
طبيعي الكلام ده مش طبيعي يعني كل بني ادم
عنده مشاكله اللي مش المفروض ان هو يجهلها
للمجتمع ولا همم
لقاء زمان كان الفنان ينتقد من قبل نقاط
محترفين او من قبل الصحافه الصفراء اليوم
الى اي مدى مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كسرت
هذا الحاجز بين الفنان وجمهوره حضرتك
الصحافه نفسها هي اللي بتخلي
الجمهور ينتقد بالطريقه دي هي اللي
بتستفزه هي اللي بتقتطع يعني جمل معينه من
الحوارات تدل على معاني الناس تخليها
تبتدي بقى تشتمه وكده فالصحافه بتشجع
الناس على ده الصح حصل دلوقتي يهمها انها
تبقى شويه لان انت فاهمه الامور دلوقت
نائمه في اوضاع كثير جدا عندنا فتبتدي بقى
او الصحافه في العالم كله هي اللي بتواجه
الجمهور ليه ذباب الفنيه
فوق خيالك يعني انت فاهمه يعني
على اطفال مثلا اطفال فنانين يبتدوا
يتنمروا على على الاهالي طب وعلاقتها ايه
ياخذ اهلنا ايه بالموضوع انت فاهمني ايه
علاقتهم بالموضوع
تنتقد انتقد فني انتقد تمثيلي انتقد ادوار
لكن لا تنتقدني كاسان في كمان طيار يقول
اذا لم يكن هناك نقد للفنان للممثل راح
تضيع الطاسه زي ما بيقولوا يعني بالعاميه
يفقد الفن الراقي هيبته هو معه يصبح كل
واحد يسمي حاله فنان كل واحد يسمي حاله
ممثل زي ما كل واحد يسمي حاله اعلامي
تمام تمام هو ده ماشي يا اما انا باقول
لحضرتك هو ممكن ينتقدني في دور ينتقدني في
عمل فني لينتقد ادائي ينتقد مصداقيتي لكن
هو ما لوش الحق ينتقد حياتي الشخصيه ما
لهوش الحق يتنمر علي انسانيه لانه انا في
الاخر انسان ولي حقوق
اذا تجاوز النقد من قبل الجمهور من النقد
البناء الى الشخصنه النقد يعني الى
التجريح الى الاهانه لشخص الفنان ما هي
حدود رد الفنان انت كيف تردين اللقاء بصي
انا بسكت كثير جدا جدا وبعد كده بصراحه ما
بقاش قادره خالص لاني باحس انه في ناس
كثير بيجيء لها اكتئاب من اصدقائي وكثير
منهم وفي ناس ممكن تتعرض ان هي مثلا تدخل
المصحات نفسيه ليه كل ده علشان ايه
فبصراحه بارد انا ما باسيبش حقي يعني يعني
سيبيه مره اثنين ثلاثه وخلاص بقى بارد
عشان اليوم برده المعلومه ما بتوصلش
بسهوله على فكره
احنا بنشكرك جزيل شكرا على دخلتك معنا من
القاهره كانت معنا عبر الهاتف فنانه لقاء
الخميس شكرا لك
ومن القاهره ينضم الينا ناقد الفني احمد
سعد الدين احمد ااه اكيد انت سمعت معانا
لقاء شو كان بتحكي الى اي مدى بالفعل
الجمهور له الحق في انتقاد الفنانين الى
اي مدى باختلاف الراي يبرر الهجوم وشخصنه
النقد
صباح الخير اولا انا سمعت فعلا الفنانه
لقاء ولكن هنا لازم نفرق ما بين حاجتين
كلمه النقد والانتقاد النقد ده ناقد
بيتكلم بيشوف اا مسلسل او عمل فني ويقدر
ان هو
ينقض مش ينتقد ينقد عناصر العمل يتعرض لها
بالايجاب والسلب ولكن هناك فارق ما بين
الانتقاد والنقد الانتقاد انا بانتقد
انسان قدامي عامل ازاي باحبه باكرهه ده
انطباعات للاسف خلال ال 20 سنه الاخيره او
ال 15 سنه الاخيره قوه السوشيال ميديا
دخلت عناصر اخرى غير النقاد المؤهلين
بمعنى ان اي واحده النهارده يمتلك صفحه
على فيسبوك ممكن يشتم فنان او فنانه او هو
عاجبه او مش عاجبه زي ما الدنيا تمشي فهنا
بيحصل جاب لابد ان احنا نبقى عارفين ان
انا لما بقيم فنان بقيموا فنيا اما الحياه
الشخصيه هناك خط فصل ما بين الحياه
الشخصيه والحياه العامه بالنسبه للفنان
يعني انا دلوقتي ممكن امسك لقاء الكنيسه
قد يكون هناك جمهور كبير مغاير ويعكسه
يعني مثلا خرج كثير من النقاد لمؤدي
المهرجانات المغني المهرجانات ولكن في
مقابلهم ملايين من الجمهورناهم
تمام ما هو هنا راي النقاد هو راي علمي
اما راي الجمهور وذوق الجمهور حاجه ثانيه
طب ما هو الجمهور اللي كان بيحب ام كلثوم
هو برده في جمهور اخر كان بيحب المطربين
الشعبيين زي احمد عدويه وغيره لكن الاهم
من ده هل احنا نختلف على اسس علميه ولا
نختلف لمجرد الاختلاف والترند الموجود
دلوقتي هي دي المشكله
التي تجزئه مقاطع كلام الفنان
بحثترنت هوس المتابعين هاوس المشاهدات
اليوم مشكله لا هو
احنا دلوقتي في زمن الترند في هواس غير
طبيعي مع انتشار اولا المواقع الاخباريه
او ال ال الاساسيه اللي هي دلوقتي معدتش
صحف المحافظه بقت المواقع الاخباريه وكمان
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الاثنين كده حصل
ما بينهم اندماج فبقى دلوقتي البحث عن
الترند بحث عن الترند هو اجزاء اي اا حديث
او حوار واخد كلمه منه وتطلع ترن سواء
كانت مع او كانت الضد بعض الفنانين لابد
ان هو او الفنانين لا لازم يبقى عارف برده
ان هو شخصيه عامه تصرفاته الطبيعيه تحت
المجهر لكن ما اجيش النهارده مع بعض
الفنانين بيبحثوا على الترند هم كمان يعني
ما جيش النهارده في مهرجان وفي فنانه جايه
لابسه همم زي ما حصل وايه يعني ما كانتش
ال- ال- اللبس بتاعها جيد ولما اتسالت
قالت والله نسي البطانه ده كلام ما هي
جايه تبحث عن ترند لكن ده موضوع صحافه
ومواقع الاخباريه
دي صراحه
في ايه في الليل قالت يعني ده موقفك بس
احنا بنشكرك لانه انتهى الوقت شكرا جزيلا
من القاهره الناقد الفني احمد سعد الدين